I don't want to see a rematch first
fight obviously Grasso chokes her out
second fight draw she didn't beat her
I'm good in lancefield deserves the next
shot and that's gonna be a tough fight
for aggresso blanchfield she's young we
need new blood in that division let's
get it rolling Chef Chango had her shot
twice didn't achieve a win
we know how that goes all set all good I
thought Grasso also won that fight we're
good I don't need a third I'm not a huge
fan of of rematches unless it's an epic
fight if it's an epic fight it's like
back and forth like oh man they just you
know throwing blows and I could give
this round to her that all right let's
run that back but when it's like this
I'm good this wasn't an epic fight I
thought Grasso won just the judges
sucked all right I'm all set let the
Young Buck in blanchfield take her stab
at it now she's gonna be a problem she's
young and we need that new it's good to
get new blood in there